foreign
it's an honor to be with you here today
and the message I have to deliver is a
simple one which is that clean energy
will win on cost definitively
but only if we get out of the way and
allow it to be built let's focus on that
first point let's look at the cost of
clean energy technology in 1975 if you
were buying a solar panel per watt of
power that It produced it would cost you
100 US dollars by 2020 that cost had
declined to 20 cents per watt of power
that's a 500 fold decline this is unlike
anything else ever seen in energy it is
unlike anything else ever seen in
physical infrastructure and it continues
today and it is likely to continue for
decades to come
now this has surprised the leading
experts on clean energy and even the
biggest optimists on the future of clean
energy I should know because I am one of
those leading optimists
in 2010 the International Energy agency
the world's foremost and official
experts on energy forecast that the cost
of solar power would drop like this now
I came from technology I was a computer
scientist and so I looked at the cost of
solar through the lens of Moore's Law
exponential decline in cost as
technology scales and so I forecast that
the cost of solar would drop at around
five times the rate that the iea
believed it would unfortunately or
fortunately I was wrong the cost of
solar actually dropped 10 times as fast
as the iea expected and twice as fast as
I expected
clean energy is a technology this
deception in understanding the pace of
cost decline has led to a massive
underestimation of the pace of growth
every year the iea puts out a forecast
for how much new solar will we install
per year and you see these colored lines
show you the pace at which the iea
believes new solar will be deployed
annually versus the black line which
shows how fast it's actually been
deployed so you see the colored lines
going off to the right those are
successive years of forecasts of annual
installations and on the left you have
what amounts to a 30 to 40 percent
annual growth in installations note this
has happened Through The covid Years
note that 2022 we'll see another 38 to
40 percent growth in this market this
trend is not limited to just solar it
applies to a wide variety of Clean
Energy Technologies we've seen the price
of Solar drop by a factor of 40 over the
last few decades we've seen the cost of
wind drop almost as much and now an
accelerating cost decline in floating
offshore wind and offshore wind we've
seen the cost of batteries that power
our electric vehicles and grid energy
storage drop at the same Pace or faster
than the pace of solar and we are just
at the very beginning of an exponential
cost decline in the cost of using clean
electricity to make hydrogen and other
fuels that we can use to power industry
to provide weeks or months of storage on
the grid and to provide fuels we can use
for Aviation for shipping and so on
what's Happening Here and I won't claim
this is happening quickly enough
to save the one degree 0.5 Celsius but
what's happening here is that Clean
Energy Technologies are Technologies and
they drop in cost like technology as
they are scaled they come down in price
meanwhile fossil fuels are Commodities
and fossil fuel prices fluctuate over
time this is data from Oxford's
Institute of New Economic studies which
shows the cost of oil gas and coal
across the bottom there fluctuating over
time largely remaining flat whereas here
is the cost of Clean Energy Technologies
solar wind batteries power to Fuels all
of them dropping exponentially
in 2010 there was no place on Earth
where clean energy was cheaper than
fossil energy in 2015 we started to see
the first instances of clean energy
without subsidies being cost competitive
now we see in more and more parts of the
world that it is cheaper to build solar
and wind than it is to put fuel into an
already built and operating coal or gas
plant and behind that is the continued
cost decline of batteries and hydrogen
which are still expensive but will get
cheap enough to solve many of our
intermittency issues now does that mean
we are done and the problem is solved
not at all we need to go faster and we
have a number of barriers some of these
we've talked about critical minerals
need to be built out we have need a just
transition but there's two barriers I
want to talk about in particular which
are the reluctance to build not in my
backyard and the challenges with
permitting because we look at Renewables
and a common complaint is they take up
too much land all of us want clean
energy infrastructure but many of us
don't want it in our backyard now solar
power is fairly compact wind power takes
more space but that space is co-located
with agriculture animals graze up to
wind turbines fields of crops can be
grown and yet despite this in modern
nations in Europe and North America
roughly half of the land in the UK in
Germany or the U.S is devoted to
agriculture yet Germany allows now two
percent of land in German to be used for
wind power the U.S allows local
communities to block wind power even if
it's nowhere near them if we want to
deploy clean energy we must allow it to
actually be built but the even larger
problem is this we need to build out the
grid we have a perception that Clean
Energy Technologies don't need the grid
solar and wind mean you can be off-grid
while that's easier largely the opposite
is true because solar and wind are
weather dependent they benefit much more
from continent-sized grid than do fossil
fuels and yet the same NIMBY issues and
the same permitting issues plague energy
transmission electricity transmission is
ugly and why do we need it if we can
just go off grid and local with these
Energy Technologies well here's why we
need it this is the sunshine the solar
resources of Europe the most sun is in
the south of course the most wind is in
the north by the way and this is
averaged across the year in Winter it is
much more dramatic in Winter you have 1
7 the solar resource in the UK that you
have in summer you have won six the
solar resource in Germany that you have
in summer so every model every
simulation of weather and energy demand
shows this it shows that if you want to
have the highest reliability Grid at the
lowest cost with the least carbon
emissions and the most clean energy
deployment you want to build a continent
sized Grid in Europe it would bring a
wind from the north primarily the North
Sea but also on land Hydro from the
nordics and solar from the south and
these would be counter-cyclical more sun
in the summer more wind in the winter
this is slightly oversimplified but this
is the sort of system that would allow
Europe to decarbonize its electricity
sector with some degree of storage and
hydrogen and so on nearly completely at
a lower cost than the system today that
same Oxford study I showed you says that
a rapid transition to clean energy
because the more you deploy the cheaper
it gets would save us 12 trillion
dollars on the energy system not even
counting climate damages now could we
build such a grid
of course we have the technology and the
economics in China the bulk of energy
demand is on the East Coast yet the
greatest solar resources and wind
resources are in the interior and China
is building literally scores of high
voltage power lines that transmit power
from where the sun and wind are to the
coasts where the energy demand is and
the longest of these lines right now
around quite a Shanghai line is 3 400
kilometers long it is 90 percent
efficient very low losses and it adds
maybe a penny or two to the cost of
electricity that's what's technically
feasible with current technology let
alone advances in Europe that would
allow us to transmit electricity from
Sevilla to Copenhagen to bring power
from the North Sea to anywhere in the
continent that needs it in my home
country the United States we could bring
power from the sunny wide open areas of
New Mexico to population and land dense
New York which doesn't get so much sun
and we could take wind power from the
Great Plains that are largely devoid of
population and bring it to the coasts in
Winter that is what a modern grid looks
like and yet we are not building this
now let me give you two pieces of data
that will back up my assertions about
how powerful these issues of permitting
and grid build out R and one more which
is open competition on cost what state
in the United States do you believe has
the most combined solar and wind power
today and has deployed the most solar
over the last year
you are a very smart audience it is the
great state of Texas now Texas has no
climate policies to speak of it has no
incentives for solar or wind to speak of
it does have abundant land and abundant
sun and wind we can't all duplicate that
but it has three other things we should
think about one it has an open market
for electricity where the cheapest
provider wins and that should give us
confidence of what is actually winning
two permitting in Texas is relatively
easy it's easy to build things easy to
build fossil infrastructure I don't love
that but it's easy to build clean
infrastructure and that's what's winning
out and three Texas is the easiest state
in the United States to build
electricity transmission not as easy as
I'd like but it makes it easy those last
three factors are fact factors we can
replicate in every nation every state
every geography on planet Earth and they
would accelerate this transition now in
August of 2022 we passed the largest U.S
climate bill ever inflation reduction
act in Europe we have a massive push on
clean energy as part of the energy
crisis driven by the war on Ukraine now
I want to reveal at the same time that
we failed at something in late September
2022 we had a permitting bill in the
United States that would have made it
tremendously easier to build the
continent-sized grid that we need in the
U.S it also made it easier to build
fossil fuels yet every analysis showed
that fundamentally this bill accelerated
the clean energy transition but it was
opposed by some people because of it
making it a bit easier to build fossil
fuels as well the consequence of this is
potentially dire the Princeton repeat
project led by my friend Dr Jesse
Jenkins has analyzed this and said that
up to 80 percent of the benefits of the
inflation reduction act may not manifest
if we can't accelerate the pace of
building transmission that that could
amount to as much as 800 million tons a
year of carbon emissions in the United
States that would have been eliminated
but that won't be because we don't have
the transmission capability to bring the
cheapest power
to where it's needed and boost
resilience and reliability along the way
so I believe
that a deal that makes it easier to
build even if
to get that bill passed we need to make
it a bit easier to build some fossil
infrastructure we'll win for clean
energy because clean energy simply wins
on cost
on a Level Playing Field it will
dominate the future and so if you have
confidence in this decades-long trend
that clean energy will economically
disrupt fossil fuels
then The Logical conclusion is that we
must get out of the way make permitting
easier and allow it to be built it is
time for us to build thank you very much
[Music]